[Music]
good evening at welcome to tucker
carlson tonight every American is born
with inherent rights that's what our
founding documents say and the purpose
of the US government is to protect those
rights that has been our national creed
for hundreds of years and it's worked
but the left no longer believes it
progressives have decided the Bill of
Rights applies only to people who agree
with them their views are protected by
the First Amendment your views are hate
speech the Second Amendment covers their
security detail you can't be trusted to
have a gun at home now the activists
left is telling us that people who
disagree with them no longer have
freedom of movement or Association they
can't go to the movies or go to
restaurants if they dare leave their
homes they will be surrounded by mobs
and threatened it's happening
last Friday White House press secretary
Sarah Huckabee Sanders and her family
were forced to leave a restaurant in
Virginia because the owner didn't like
their politics Sanders and her husband
went home but the rest of their family
went to another restaurant that wasn't
good enough they had committed the sin
of being related to someone who works at
the White House so progressives
continued to harangue them as they tried
to eat this is happening in a lot of
places to a lot of people protesters for
example have massed outside the home of
White House aide Stephen Miller in case
their intentions weren't clear enough
they put up mock wanted posters with
Miller's face on them a DHS employee
meanwhile found a burned decapitated
animal carcass on his front porch again
the message is crystal clear activists
on the Left are moving toward violence
they are aware of this and some applaud
it a piece yesterday in splinter news
which is owned by Univision explained
that intimidating Trump supporters in
public places is quote just the minimum
baseline here this is all going to get
more extreme and it should end quote how
extreme well the article fondly recalls
the domestic terror bombings of the
1970s thousands a year in America that's
our future
the article says unfortunately we're
headed there fast over the weekend in
Los Angeles congressman Maxine Waters
urged the mob to hunt down and find
members of the president's cabinet
here's part of it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Maxine Waters isn't just any member of
Congress The Daily Beast calls her quote
a folk hero
BuzzFeed describes her as the
unchallenged new face of the Democratic
Party and indeed she is she's also a
self-described civil rights leader which
makes it a little weird to see her
demanding that certain people be denied
public accommodations sorry we don't
serve your kind at the lunch counter
that's exactly what she is saying and
she said it again yesterday I stand by
my speech in saying that the protests
have already started they're probably
going to continue the message of all
this is clear the left no longer
considers its political opponents fellow
citizens or even human how long before
they start openly calling for something
bad to happen to those opponents well in
the case of Maxine Waters it won't be
the first time in 1992 waters cheered as
racist mobs burned Los Angeles as she
put it at the time riot is the voice of
the unheard when Reginald Denny was
dragged from his truck and nearly
murdered for the color of his skin
beaten in the head with a cinderblock on
camera
waters championed his attackers she
partied with them after their trial
Maxine Waters has a record of endorsing
mob violence everyone in Washington
knows that Democrats don't care
to his credit Chuck Schumer did call
waters his most recent remarks
not American good for him but hardly
anyone else said anything Nancy Pelosi
blamed Donald Trump for what water said
that was a theme stop hitting me they
said as they threw the first punch I
feel that we are in pre Nazi Germany the
stages of things that are occurring on a
daily basis the obfuscation the lies the
totalitarian behavior is shocking and
horrendous they follow the exact pattern
that Hitler has he is evil he is evil
and the thing is I thought I'll come in
and he won't really know because he's
not that smart he doesn't you know he'll
just do a showmanship thing but he's
evil this is about racism this is pure
and simple racism that's all it says the
people who support him are frightened to
death of this country becoming the
Browning of America something
interesting has happened as progressives
become more authoritarian and less
tolerant they seem more convinced that
they're fighting actual Nazis rather
than their fellow Americans with whom in
the scheme of things they have only
relatively mild political differences
the more they accuse the administration
of extremism the more extreme they
become and that's not surprising because
once you decide that the people who
disagree with you are Nazis everything
is allowed why wouldn't you threaten
them in restaurants or burn their houses
down or who knows this could very well
end in tragedy you start talking like
this and you don't know where it's going
to go some progressives seem to welcome
all that Quentin James is the head of a
political action committee that supports
Democrats recently announced that those
calling for calm are quote accomplices
of the current administration
accomplices this is the language of
total war it's scary it has no place in
politics we're heading towards something
awful and the only people who can stop
it are the adults on the left and there
are still some Democratic members of
Congress entertainment figures religious
leaders media chieftains like Jeff
Zucker at CNN or Andy lack at NBC
they're silent now cowering and
complicit in all of this but the country
badly needs them to cool the rhetoric
and rein in the mob no more Nazi talk on
their TV channels no more screaming at
people in
restaurants there is a point of no
return and we are approaching it and we
need their help to pull back